wanda with this movie we obviously see
her introduced and like big ingrained
into the world of magic but in the
comics she is obviously a massive part
of the x-men as well
and knowing that that is coming in the
next few years i'm curious if that is
something on your radar and that you're
at all preparing for this guy
you just got me excited
because i keep i don't really know what
i do next after this movie i don't
really know
i want to know what fans want and like
what the ideas are but i don't
[Applause]
you know i just love how sweet elizabeth
olsen is when it comes to like fan
casting and fan opinions it would be so
easy for any of the cast degree to just
be like you know you thought it was this
but we actually never talked about that
where she's like no
tell me what you want right like i i
love that approach and like she
obviously seems very mindful of the fans
and like i love that about her and like
it
comes through in their performance in in
the movie well uh lizzie olson we can't
wait to see you again and thank you so
much to cinemablend for asking the great
questions and giving us a great
interview clip welcome back to new
rockstars we have now crossed the
threshold into an mcu on the other side
of doctor strange the multiverse of
madness spoiler warning but that mcu has
been officially codified now with the
numerical designation of earth dimension
616. but what the what does this mean
for the comics universe of 616 uh which
comics have suggested exists separate
within the multiverse alongside the
universe of the films i swear to god
we're not just some nerds overthinking
this the answer is extremely important
to how we look at the issue going
forward as x-men someday join the fray
as wanda returns to join that fray but
will she be even invited to this party
because we gotta say after watching this
movie
the [ __ ] is going on what about jeez
[Laughter]
you can get in there together too well
give us your one of them come on oh my
god language with me i can't even
believe you even said that i didn't know
i was allowed to swear on this show i
never know what i'm allowed to when i'm
not
the rules are different when we dream
walk into our inside marvel variant
selves the potty mouth it's unleashed
that's the rules that's how it works
here let me try this out
darn
i feel bad already
it's inside marvel everyone it's new
rockstar's weekly marvel reaction show
we have now moved on from our moon night
coverage to unpack your biggest
questions after doctor strange the
multiverse of madness i'm eric boss and
with me today are two of my favorite
people mt what's going on and whitney
van leningham hi hello thank you for
inviting me i'm really excited you guys
mm-hmm we're happy to have you happy
sweet yeah invitation this morning to
come on the show and i was like yes we
invited her by hogwarts owl
uh yes they did hogwarts out it showed
up at my house i was like brushing my
teeth and all of a sudden
a bunch of letters right in the face
feathers everywhere we're sorry about
those uh talon scars you know they'll
heal up
those usually heal up fast um luckily
usually well i wanted more hands on deck
this week to uh to unpack this movie
we're gonna have four weeks really
before at least four before uh miss
marvel hits us where we can really just
figure out what just happened in
multiverse of madness and how the whole
landscape has changed uh i am still
processing this movie i had a blast the
three times i saw it in theaters um but
and one of my favorite audience
reactions each of the three times i saw
it was uh when 838 christine palmer says
that they have designated dr strange's
home reality the universe of the mcu
films as quote universe 616. without
fail that line always got either a cheer
or a cast or some kind of murmur
i don't know about you but our man bruce
campbell
clearly all these bros who screamed
let's go and toby mcguire no way home
didn't actually watch sam raimi
spider-man films because bruce
campbell's a huge part of all of those
folks i got to just say there's more to
rainy spider-man than just your bully
maguire memes but either way we're going
to spend today's episode unpacking what
exactly the 616 designation means and
how it fits into the logic of the past
mcu films as well as the comics what it
tells us now about where we're headed um
but be sure to check out
newrockstarsmerch.com to see our latest
latest obsession shirt called shattered
madness this limited edition shirt is
inspired by dr strange the multiverse of
madness and like all of our latest
obsession shirts one is once it's gone
it's gone for good so support the
channel check out all of our new awesome
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerge.com
all right uh uh mt if you don't mind i'm
gonna let whitney ask the questions okay
yes
all right the question today is what
does it mean for the mcu to be labeled
universe 616. what is that what's that
going to do to our multiverse what's
that going to do to the others
great question whitney so a doctor
strange in america chavez traveled to
earth 838 and are taking the baxter
foundation where e3 christine explains
that she has designated this universe
that they're in currently is 838 but the
universe where stephen strange came from
the mcu at 616. now 616 of course is a
numerical designation of the uh primary
marvel universe in the comics it was
actually devised in 1983 by comics
writer david thorpe you should go read
this interview it's incredible uh he he
decided to do this for a captain britain
reboot and you know back in the 80s
these marvel writers they're like yeah
i'll just do whatever they had no idea
that it would turn into this whole
freaking thing where the axis of the
cinematic universe is all based on this
he's just like i don't know i just
thought it'd be fun to do that
which is why i think we need to track
all these comics writers down and pay
them their money yeah stop just giving
them special thanks and the credits in
these movies give them a cut give them a
little bit of your gazillion dollars
disney come on without them none of this
would exist
there's not much money they should just
be giving it away to these people
seriously everything they write was word
for hire i get that now
i get that it's marvel owns it all but
still just you know kick him back a
little bonus give him something give him
huey dewey or louie at least one of them
you have plenty of them you have
multiples
but i love this quote because he said uh
they wanted the captain britain core to
be more of a multiversal organization in
this reboot and he said that uh the 616
universe was selected as quote the worst
performing earth that was holding the
others back now why did he choose the
number 616 well get this thorpe said
that he gave many people alternate
answers over the years but the truth is
that he based it on
666 the number of the beast minus 50. he
just shows a nice round number away from
the most frightening yo honestly i was
getting crazy vibes from 616. so it's
really funny
that that is actually the answer
dude i have no idea that makes me like
it more yeah
[Laughter]
now ever since then in the comics 616
has been the number of the maine marvel
universe the one with peter parker
spider-man the universe where bucky is
forever dead that changed with the
ultimates universe in the early 2000s
where a lot of these things were changed
of course miles morales became
spider-man um but these numerical
designations came up whenever
multiversal stories were were the focus
so like the spider-verse comics the
secret wars comics where we saw the
incursion between 616 and 1610.
but now
uh the fact that the mcu is being called
616 you could totally just take that to
mean that this is how marvel studios is
now codifying the primary universe of
the movies the movie universe being an
adaptation of the comics universe but
it's a bit more complicated than that
because until now the mcu film universe
has been considered a distinct separate
universe alongside the comics universe
both of them part of a a trans media
multiverse of different universes so the
comics universe has been 616. the mcu
has been earth
19999 that label came from kevin feige
quotes where he was joking that he
wanted the marvel uh studios films to
last for uh 199
999 years
um
and there have been various easter eggs
that we talked about hinting that the
film universe could have been connected
to 616 so like in avengers in game scott
lang storage locker hit 616 written on
the sign in spider-man far from home
mysterio quentin beck claimed to be from
earth dimension 833 whereas this
universe was earth dimension 616 and
we've talked about how weird that now is
considering quentin beck wasn't from an
alternate universe he was just
fabricating all of this so he just
happened to pull the right number out
yeah that's hilarious that work well
gutermin was obviously a watcher or a
tva agent or something
only way it makes sense i like to think
that like what if like the fantastic
four wrote that book that gutermin was
reading that'd be really fun i don't
know oh maybe maybe you gotta look at
the byline on that that was written by
mr b grimm
it's all like written in like a new york
accent like from the streets like nobody
oh sorry continue
but most critically of all these easter
eggs loki episode one um an episode also
conceived of by michael waldron the
screenwriter of a madness
the tva film strip of loki's mcu life
and death is labeled 616. we'll talk
about that a bit later but meanwhile in
captain america the first avenger kids
in the 1940s of the mcu history were
reading issues of captain america number
one with the same exact comic cover of
cat punching hitler implying 616 comics
exist within the mcu and if you're a cop
if you're an avid comic reader you may
just be struggling with the 616
designation because again there is
evidence that comics versions of loki
and the young avengers have actually
visited the universe of the mcu films
within the pages of those comics so that
would imply both that the 616 universe
and the mcu universe are separate but
the problem with that is after we watch
this movie guys uh america chavez in the
comics america chavez identifies herself
as the only version of her that exists
across the multiverse but america chavez
in the movie says the same exact thing
that would imply at least from the point
of view of marvel studios and kevin
feige that they consider the movies to
just be an adaptation of the comics
universe not a separate universe that
exists alongside it across
a film and print media landscape that's
connected um but i think another clue to
this being the case even though it's
from another studio in another medium
even 2018 spider-man into the
spider-verse remember that movie also
uses the marvel comics numerical
designations peter parker six and six
miles morales 1610 uh now while that
movie is of course animated and it does
pretty closely follow miles morales
origin in the comics like he takes over
for peter parker after he dies in the
1610 reality it's not exactly the same
they took some liberties with that movie
um so if we were to just assume the 1610
in that movie is the same as the 1610 of
the comics we would really just negate
everything brian michael bendis did
sarah shelly did to actually create
those panels and the words of the comics
pages in favor of just the animators of
the movie and what they created so i
think the best way this is just me i
think the best way to look at this is
there is a 1610 in the comics there's
also a 1610 in the movies i think you
mean six minutes
one more time
two times oh yeah well that's
technically true but anyway they're all
true or whatever yeah so really this is
just me but the best way to look at this
is there is a 616 in the comics and
there's a 616 in the movies and both are
valid both are true one isn't more
important than the other but that's just
my take on it empty whitney i want to
know what you make of this man all i
know is this is about to
make my research work at this company 10
million times harder because now when i
google stuff instead of doing mcu and
616 separately i'm gonna be like okay
wait but
mcu-616 for this but comic 616 for this
like
so for the purposes of my job a little
frustrated however in general very
stoked i think it's i think it's a cool
idea i don't see why there can't be an
adaptation for film
so many book mediums do that it's the
same thing with like i mean let's just
look at the twilight saga shall we like
that's
no i actually i've never actually read
twilight so i have no idea i know it's
about vampires but
it's about so much more than vampires
there's also werewolves in it there's
also
morbius guys we all know this it's a
morbius prequel well good goddamn why
didn't you say that sooner now i have to
get on it
empty i want to know your take on the
616. is it a hard and fast rule now that
the mcu is is 616. are there other ways
to look at this i i honestly believe
that the whole 616 designation is
primarily like
it sort of just means home in terms of
what medium that you're looking at it
from so for example the mcu is
considered 616 because it's the main
home universe that we're all familiar
with so like whatever the the home is of
all these characters that we know that
is going to be 616. so therefore like
you know in um well in into the spider
verse it's a little bit different
because like you said peter parker um
was from the 616 and then like miles
morales like in the comics is in 1610 so
like because of that miles morales story
it's a little bit different there but in
general like in in in the comics when we
have 616 if they're just basically
saying this is the main universe in like
all the other universes in the comics
like 1610 and like earth 242 which is
one of my personal favorites which is an
earth just completely on fire it's just
all of fire it just doomed um
it's just the meme with the dog but the
whole universe yes
it's literally that but the entire
planet earth 242.
this is fine planet um so yeah those
like it's from the perspective of like
that main universe so like it makes
sense to me that the mcu is called 616
because from our perspective of these
gods reading these comics like earth
1999
is like that has to be the designation
because there's so many six one sixes
for us like we have a zillion 616 so we
need like a really ridiculous number to
specifically designate the mcu so i
think it all really boils down to the
perspective
of who is is um
in the universe and like if they're the
main characters of that universe if that
makes sense i hope that makes sense
i hear what you're saying in mt that
like within the universe of of the
context like the way we should interpret
the universe is that 616 is just like
the template it's the baseline
i think we should point out that it was
838 christine palmer who named it 616 in
this context so to her it's not her home
but it's it's her it's her way of
acknowledging to like us that like
where we came from
you the viewer 616 is basically zero
it's basically yeah a ground zero of
wherever the multiverse is yeah
essentially so like if if if the
character is not part of like the main
universe then like they were going to
call the main universe 616 because
it's the universe that like we are
familiar with it's the mcu so like they
sort of have to go
like the writers have to write it so
like all right christine palmer from
another universe is going to call the
main mcu 616 because it has to be like
organized for all the viewers at home to
know that like this is just home home
base and so uh yeah yeah
yeah i think the
the the griping that we're probably
still gonna hear either in the comments
or on social media are the comics
readers who still firmly believe that
the mcu is actually earth 199.9999 and
we cannot trust uh 838 christine palmer
that she's just like that's just what
she names it but that's not what it is
called objectively in the mcu but my
counter argument to that would be the
tva film strip the tva is a pretty solid
authority that is not
attached to any one reality or any one
universe even and they labeled loki's
mcu reality as 616. i think that's a
pretty solid i mean to me that's a
pretty solid compelling argument that
like objectively in the mcu marvel
studios wants us to see the mcu is
called 616. and i think if you could
just like step back from what you read
in the comics and just look at it
objectively kevin feige is trying to
simplify this for everybody and and
everybody who's watching this movie who
maybe hasn't read those specific young
adventures or saw that loki passport and
said oh well loki visited the movies
i think it's just
his simple way of saying this universe
is 616. that's just what we're calling
it now um yeah and you called it 19999
based off of a joke that i said but
that's never
my abuse
but i think um my question for you guys
now is like
is if if this is true then it was
originally based on 666
is the implication of that that like
there is a marvel 666
and that is the mark of the beast that
might be in the emcee where we meet with
pisto
that i wouldn't i'm looking it up right
now that would be banana there has to be
an earth 666 at this point but we've had
so many designations yeah they're like
they're that's right they're totally
after it's 666.
and that's where i was born babies
there there is an earth 666 in the
comics also known as earth 4680 it is uh
the realm of a brother it's where
brother voodoo hid the orb of necromancy
put it deep in schumacher's ego maze uh
it is a hellish hellish dimension with
all kinds of supernatural entities like
bands
mummies etc so
there could be a uh a dimension of that
in the mc in the live action mcu now
it's totally possible earth's success is
impossible
my god like i do love me some brother
tell universe of the mcu i want to go
live in the metal version of the
multiverse
yeah it's good
and who do i think that it's quite
possible that we could end up going
there in doctor strange three
considering that we do go to the dark
dimension with clea and like that is a
dark realm so maybe we're gonna be
hopping to different darker universes i
think that'd be really fun like earth
666 all right i have some more questions
i want to talk with you all about uh
with multiverse of madness first i want
to thank some people who helped us make
this episode thank you to our sponsors
helix sleep even if you have a magical
armor that appears out of nowhere to
help you fight crime you still need a
good night's sleep on a mattress made
just for you well our friends at helix
mattress are here to make sure you have
that helix sleep has a quiz that matches
your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you they have soft medium burn
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even helix
plus matches for plus size sleepers i
have a helix mattress i love it empty
you got a helix mattress yes i sleep on
it every night i've loved it like every
single like week of that i've had it
it's my sleep has never been better i
have a different kind of mattress and
i'm dead now
my bones creak daily i'm i'm now from
the multiverse where i'm dead in that
reality because my mattress isn't as
good as mt and eric's
make it happen
well the mattress ships right to your
door for free no need to go to a
mattress store just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you're gonna love it helix
is offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com inside
marvel we also want to thank brooklyn
for sponsoring this episode do you wish
you could travel to a universe full of
super comfortable bedding well good news
you're already living it this version of
the multiverse has brook linen brook
linen home of the internet's favorite
sheets was created in 2014 to give
customers luxury hotel level home
essentials that don't break the bank
they offer everything from snuggly
sheets to cozy towels and robes
loungewear accessories and much more by
working directly with suppliers brooklyn
cuts out the markups and passes those
savings back to their customers so you
get their incredible products at a
reasonable cost treat yourself with
brook linens linen sheets they're super
airy and feature a trendy wrinkled look
that is oh so stylish bed making
optional my friends no need to make the
bed first time trying brooklyn well
their best-selling lux sheets are the
perfect place to start featuring an
irresistibly soft feel and a buttery
smooth finish so go to brooklyn.com use
promo code inside marvel to get 20 off
your purchase of 100 or more that's b r
o o k l i n e n dot com enter the promo
code inside marvel for 20 off your
purchase today at brooklyn and the
curators of comfort all right shifting
gears here uh there's an important
conversation happening around multiverse
madness that i think we need to have
here on new rock stars um a lot of
people watching this movie uh feel that
it is pretty disconnected with the way
they saw wanda vision that wanted vision
was a story of uh you know a mother and
a wife overcoming her grief um and then
by the end of that learning some
critical lessons
and then they feel like this movie
does want his character dirty it might
undo some of her character development
from one division
it's obviously a very complicated
conversation to have but i i think we
can have it respectively here as best as
we can uh so i i want to ask everyone
here do we feel like multiverse of
madness undid wanda's character
development from one division and even
if it did how did that affect your
viewing of this movie i don't think so
at all i i do not get that criticism at
all considering
the ending of one division and how wanda
the last shot was wanda reading the
darkhold and the one thing that the dark
hole does is exactly what happened in
the multiverse of madness i don't
understand why people weren't expecting
this to happen
this is literally the one thing that
everyone says that the dark hole does it
corrupts you so like the character
development of wanda vision yeah she did
learn the lessons but that was before
she read the darkhold and picked up all
the lessons that she learned so like i
don't understand
what people are really surprised about
personally because that's just the dark
holes and like that's just what i think
mt
this is this gets to a thing i think a
lot of folks view post-credits scenes
different than other fans i you know i i
know when i watch a post-credits scene
that's how i walk out of a theater
that's like my last uh lasting image or
like click off of a screening yeah that
mountain cabin was pretty big but i
think for a lot of people who watch one
division and this is a completely valid
interpretation that they really view the
ending as her saying goodbye to her kids
saying goodbye to vision letting the
hecks die um
learning the lesson of what is love uh
what is grief if not love persevering to
them that is the emotional climax and
ending and resolution of wanda vision uh
not this post-credits scene and i think
a lot of them secretly didn't like that
post-credits scene but uh uh but whitney
i want to get you in on this
conversation yeah man
i'm actually of the camp that it's not
that i didn't like that they did this i
think that it absolutely makes sense and
the dark cold explanation absolutely
makes sense but i think that i was also
one of the people who i really felt very
strongly connected to the way that one
division ended and i really like i also
took away like oh like i love that like
in their last conversation together you
know vision says who knows what i'll be
next you know and that kind of to me was
like the closer of that that was like
okay you might not have your family in
this way ever again
but somewhere out there you know that
that's what's going on and so i that's
how i kind of interpreted the end of one
division so i was a little bit surprised
but i think that the reason why isn't
that i was surprised that this happened
in multiverse of madness i think that
because so much of that corruption
happened off screen like we know that
that's what the dark hole does like we
are very aware but we kind of didn't get
to see that like day by day decline into
absolute madness like we see that cabin
you know that she's in and the cabin
looks fine and then all that and then we
see the orchard and everything zooms out
and the cabin's all dilapidated and
gross and it's like whoa how'd we get
there from the end of one division to
now
um so i think that it does make sense
and the darkhold thing does make sense
and it makes a lot more sense too if you
watch
um the collider interview with elizabeth
olsen where she explains that she felt
like
she was playing a version of wanda in
this movie where she might have been
divorced from vision or they might not
be together anymore they might be
separated she might have moved on and
the most important aspect to her was
just finding her children so after i
read that
and knowing what the dark hole
done gonna go and do to you i do i do
agree that it was the right choice for
the movie i think that for me what would
have really
melded
my love for the ending of wanda vision
and the beginning of this
is if we had just a little bit more of
that on-screen corruption i think would
have helped me and maybe helped other
viewers but i didn't hate it i love this
movie i think it's great it's so much
fun it's so spooky i just i just cried
so hard at the ending of wanda vision
you guys i just loved it so much and
it's a good ending it's a really
emotional ending i really loved it
you make us so many good points whitney
i i think you're 100 right that seeing
that journey that descent off screen or
on screen would have helped so much even
if it was it didn't need to be more of a
post-credits scene i mean maybe it would
have helped to see some of those trees
around the cabin start to corrupt or get
twisted or something like that
but i think we just needed more context
around the dark hole in general bringing
in the dark hold earlier in one division
now in fairness to marvel it seemed like
they were producing a lot of the stuff
concurrently out of order than what they
expected you know
i'm not sure it seemed like multiverse
of madness might like originally one
division was just supposed to come out
the spring of the same year multiverse
madness was kind of come out we don't
know if it was gonna be before or after
or what um but like yeah it seems like
they weren't totally clear what was
gonna get introduced when yeah whether
the dark hole was gonna be introduced in
multiverse of madness and then that was
gonna give us our context for the book
and it seemed like maybe they would had
to suddenly introduce it on wanna vision
but um you know our friends at uh our
colleagues at the ringer verse podcast
joanna robertson uh robinson
mallory rubin
did an amazing amazing deep dive uh into
multiverse of madness and and talked
about this so eloquently and one thing's
joe pitched was if we had just seen
another multiversal version of wanda
that uh showed her without needing her
kids like we just saw a wanda without
her kids and that wanda was fine that
might have done a lot
to undo a lot of the the bad taste in
people's mouths because then we could
have seen oh this this woman isn't
defined by whether or not she has kids
you know right she's not in that line of
like i'm not a monster i'm a mother just
felt a little like
like we don't
women aren't defined
solely
and it would have been great if we could
have just seen one other
one other uh
variant of wanda just to like give us
that you know just to show this one as
just a unique
uh mother uh a unique one i want a new
girl wanda i want that new girl variant
to blonde
that's with jade johnson of the voice
it's scarlet witch
[Laughter]
i mean we already saw a bit of that in
one division right i want to mention
episode seven or eight one of them did
kind of like the opening was a bit new
girly yeah we should have straight up
had a new girl episode of bond division
are you kidding me like that's hilarious
oh man
um i i think what surprised me most
about this is like how much like i love
one of it to me it's like one of the
loki day by day it it changes which one
is at the top of my marvel disney plus
shows ranking um and i think what i love
so much about it it's just how much of a
love letter it was to television history
and uh how great elizabeth olsen was and
captain so good that they were and
playing up those tropes the whole cast
it's just such a cool show
unlike anything i've ever seen um and
but to me like people coming down to
multiverse of madness really viewing
wandavision as like
sacred text
that uh can be undone in any way i'm
like i walked out of that show feeling
like another slightly confusing marvel
show marvel title that broke the rules
to me this is the his this is marvel's
legacy every mcu title undoes certain
things about what led to it i mean thor
ragnarok was completely sacrilege to so
much about thor oh that's what we like
about it that's why we like it though
it's fun
yeah yeah
all of these completely changed things
we thought about the characters i
definitely caught myself i had to have a
talk with myself where i was like yeah
but i really miss what happened and who
knows when i'll be next and it makes me
cry and then i was like whitney you're
being one of those fans who's so
attached to something that they can't
like see outside of themselves in their
own mirror and i was like it's because i
see myself so much in this show that i
can't like that i'm like that's why it's
precious to me because it's me you know
and so it's like that i had to catch
myself and be like when you dumbass
[ __ ] just enjoy the god damn the movie
just like you know like honestly i feel
like this helped i did i just talked
myself out of being a toxic like
parasocial relationship with the scarlet
witch i don't know how i did it but i
didn't think that's toxic
i don't think yeah i think that this is
like a huge testament towards like
marvel studios and the types of stories
that they're telling and the fact that
they are able to grab a hold of you that
hard like it really is like they just
grab onto your goddamn heart and squish
it like it's wanda ripping ultron's oil
machine out of his chest like that's how
they get you
yeah um and and with yeah i think your
your reactions to that your your love of
that line from vision i i i don't think
about that line a lot but you're right
that it was such a cool it's my favorite
line i literally cry eric every single
time i've had to re-watch that scene
like for work i have started fully
sobbing at my desk fully every single
time i like i love it so much it makes
me so happy and sad at the same time
yeah and in the same way that i'm seeing
a lot of um like uh marvel twitter which
is something that i normally fear
very scary very scary indeed a lot of a
lot of people are taking specific lines
from this movie which is you know people
are like
being really hard on the writing of this
movie but there are some beautiful lines
some
lines in this movie where just out of
context
you could argue it's out of context but
i think that people are completely
respecting the context where wanda says
i'd blow a hole in my husband's head and
it meant nothing yeah like or i love you
in every universe like so many of these
lines are connecting with people and i
don't want to take that away from anyone
uh at all i think ultimately whatever
you feel whatever you take away from a
movie is completely fine it's true for
you and that's true in your heart i
think what becomes an issue is when
people go online and try to deny each
other
each other yeah exactly yeah and i don't
think any of us want to do that um and
honestly that's what makes movies so
much fun and stupid twitter forgets this
but it's like it's okay that all of us
have a completely different experience
and reaction to something because we're
all different people and we have
different stories ourselves so of course
we're going to connect to different
things differently so
i would never say you can't feel your
dang feels
your emotional truth while consuming a
piece of content is not universally
everyone's emotional truth that they all
[Laughter]
well speaking of reactions uh and um
people's subjective reactions to things
being totally okay one of my favorite
things about seeing a movie and as
packed of a crowd as crowd of a movie
theater as i can is just hearing the
random
weird stuff that people vocalize while
they're watching the movie so i wanted
to uh have in this episode with justice
chatting about when we saw this movie in
the theater in the past week what were
some of the most surprising and weirdest
reactions you heard either from yourself
or from people around you
while you saw this movie
okay i for one the part that made me
actively laugh out loud i was the only
person laughing and my boyfriend had to
kick me and be like you stupid it's not
a funny scene was when
charles xavier shows up in the in the
mindscape and he's cosplaying steve jobs
he's just
steve jobs is professor x
all the introducing i still can't stop
laughing about it
whitney you just answered a huge
question for me because when i saw it
someone burst out laughing when patrick
stewart showed up in the turtleneck and
i was like what is so funny about this
you were hearing me laugh all the
[Laughter]
does this person know what's coming have
they seen it already and they know what
where this or is it just like that
nervous laughing they're like oh no he's
gonna die no it was specifically steve
jobs themed laughter
steve jobs xavier
professor jobs um why not
so i for for me like everyone cheered at
krasinski like obviously
oh yeah but crickets to bruce campbell
like did you guys i got absolute
crickets to bruce campbell it was very
weird and i was like that's bruce
campbell guys what's wrong with you
that's bruce that's the joke
i saw it in a pro bruce campbell theater
we were we were hollering we were
dragging each other to hell it was great
we brought the bruce campbell discord
over to the theater
pizza papa
pizza papa my favorite mcu character
pizza
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i feel like this implies that pizza papa
is also a pimp
it sounds like he always gets paid i'm
like ah does that even what does that
mean i don't know
um anyway um but no i think though a
weird reaction for me well one of the
funniest was was obviously when princess
kranzinski came up because uh like i was
sitting next to you a couple and like
the girlfriend seemed like she wasn't
really into marvel movies and she was
like oh my god is that jim and i just
cracked up i was like she was so excited
for jim i was like you know what
worth the price of
admission because like that's that's too
awesome it was too old i would have just
turned to her and i would have been like
yes [ __ ] in this multiverse he's uh
he actually was a paper salesman from
scranton believe it or not
yeah
i know
i love both minds when it comes to these
things because on one hand i am writing
notes when i go see these movies and
it's work for me which sucks and it's
work for me i mean you guys are also now
now that you work with new rock stars
you have to write some movies too um but
like me and then there's something with
my phone
baby
oh no oh no whitney we need to we need
to have a workshop on like how to just
like keep your place and write shorthand
so you don't oh dude i tried that i
tried the eric method once you told me
and it smeared my pen all over my page
it was just a whole slur by the end of
it
you gotta use you gotta use a pencil
well my thinking is like i just want to
be able to hear the lines what drives me
nuts is like when i first saw this movie
the first screening i did not hear the
ron wasserman
i didn't catch that till the second
screening thank god i saw it you know
the second time yeah um so like yeah
like it bumps you out when you're like
you don't you can go or you go yeah you
can start clapping but you do not need
to scream let's go
for a six count
i was one of the let's goers but like i
wasn't very loud but when i did hear
that um franklin and valeria existed i
was like yeah let's go cause i love
valeria so much like she's one of my
favorite marvel characters valeria
richards so like i'm so happy so i get i
did literally
short short little bursts are fine in
fact when i saw no way home uh the
second or third time i saw no way home
there was a guy who's sitting next to me
who like when matt murdock showed up and
people go yeah he goes shut up
shut up
jesus
christ shut up shut your goddamn face
you gotta you gotta let people do their
do their thing
relax man like i'm the one with the
notepad and i'm not shushing people like
come on bro
wow their devil's a religion for some
people man they take them very seriously
i guess so
i think the most surprise there were two
surprising one was like for me when uh i
mean sam rainey i know sam rainey i love
sam raimi from the evil dead army of
darkness drag me to hell all of his
non-spider-man stuff i love a good sam
remy jump scare and with sam raimi's
horror gets goofy i think sam raimi
wants us to kind of giggle at some of
his campy horror that's part of the fun
of it and there is a moment where like
uh
you know when it cut when
when doctor strange is stream walking
into the zombie defender strange i know
what you're going to do sam raimi
hilariously cuts back to dr strange
where benedict cumberbatch patches just
going
and i giggle i'm like that's that's
freaking hilarious and i got a quarter
turn someone in the row in front of me
goes
how dare you like they didn't say it
just give me that look is it why
dude why i was like come on man if
you've never seen a sam raimi everybody
wants us to laugh at this are you
kidding me that is a comedicly time take
that's
funny it's i mean so i felt a little bad
but i'm like man people everyone's cut
from a different cloth that's fine but
to me my favorite was when um professor
x goes just because someone stumbles and
loses their way doesn't mean they lost
forever which i to me i was like oh i
think that was in days of future past
there was one guy behind me who goes
yeah
[Applause]
one day's a future past nerd who knew
that script word for word recognized
that line right away he converted it to
me oh i guess it was from days of future
honestly we make videos for that guy
that's right
[Laughter]
so
we want to hear from all of you in the
comments below
only tell we don't want to hear any of
your other comments just tell us the
other crazy reactions that you heard
during your screening that's my favorite
thing about watching a movie in a
crowded theater tweet us the the
funniest thing you heard in the theater
uh i'm just gonna give you another
example uh what i saw in game there was
a son and his dad this is like the third
time i saw it on like the following
tuesday so the theater wasn't fully
packed fully but the dad was sleeping
through most of the movie and then uh
his son kept having to explain to him
who everyone was i thought it was so so
sweet
this guy was like in his 60s or
something like that and just like
clearly didn't get anything that was
happening
and then uh and then at the very end of
the movie an old cap shows up he leans
over to his son and goes hey that's a
clintus wood
yeah i know this one i got this one kids
[Music]
richard's reactions hit youtube because
like i i need to watch those like those
give me sarah yeah oh it's so good so
good i love movies and i love you guys
thank you for joining
us this week for inside marvel uh and
over the weeks ahead we're gonna be
talking more and more about uh other
loose cues that you got about music
hit us up on twitter
why did you tell us your loose keys so
gross eric why did you save like
use some starch tighten up those cues
hey don't forget to check out our great
marvel merch options at neuroxmerch.com
if uh you're over 18 check out the new
rockstar's discord server in the
description enjoy that conversation
where they're weirdly critical of all of
us uh and
follow me at ea boss follow mt at
mastertainment uh follow whitney at
whitney puppy yes don't forget to
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast thank you for watching
we'll see you next week
you